my first foray into ancestors the
humankind Odyssey was to put it bluntly
confusing a warning popped up and
demanded I dodged out of the way of what
I couldn't be sure not knowing what to
do
I couldn't respond in time and an unseen
attack left me both bleeding and
poisoned I had absolutely no idea where
I should go or how to fix myself I began
to wander and thankfully about thirty
minutes later I found the rest of my
clan as it turns out that first journey
where I blindly limped in different
directions in hopes of finding someone
to help me is a fairly accurate
depiction of what ancestors regularly
entails the game prides itself on giving
you as little information as it can and
daring you to rely on your ingenuity and
resourcefulness to survive though the
game fulfills its promise to do the
former it fails to deliver a compelling
reason as to why you'd even want to rise
up to the challenge of the latter
[Music]
in Ancestors you play as a member of an
ape clan and 10 million BC Africa and
you try to ensure your lineage continues
through to 2 million BC to survive that
long you need to manage how much you eat
drink and sleep while also steering
clear of predators and taking care of
injuries as you interact with more
aspects of the world you grow smarter
and acquire new skills which you can
then pass on to your descendants every
second of real world time translates
into a minute in game to speed things
along your endgame Progress produces
opportunities to further clan evolution
and make large jumps ahead in time and
with every new generation of apes you
get an opportunity to evolve the process
moves you to a new calculated placement
on the timeline that's dependent on
which advancements you make beforehand
[Music]
it's definitely not easy though
especially since your clan needs to
sustain itself throughout those eight
million years in a single lineage though
your clan mates learn what you do in
real time losing an entire clan means
you have to restart from a brand new
lineage and relearn everything you've
previously discovered if your clan dies
after they've adapted to eating fish for
example you not only need to go through
the entire process of reacquainting your
diet but you'll have to teach your Apes
how to make fishing Spears all over
again
when it's a few minutes of knowledge
lost it's not that big of a deal but
when you're losing hours of progress it
can be demoralizing instead of saving
your skills and knowledge between runs
ancestors records your progress by
keeping track of how far you travel you
can discover and unlock new starting
points ranging from a lush forest to a
Plains filled savanna unlocking these
new start points provides welcome
variety as each environment contains its
own unique ecosystem of creatures and
plants as well as its own set of weather
based challenges but your primates
always begin in the same clueless state
even if you already know what to do
you'll have to recreate everything
you've done to get back to where you
were in the evolutionary process before
your clan was wiped out this gameplay
loop can be immensely frustrating and
it's one that gets more drawn out the
more you play there's nothing in the
game that allows you to recover from a
failure and quickly rebuild what's been
lost either which is disheartening when
your downfall is your own fault and
downright frustrating when it's just bad
luck having to redo everything you've
already done also keeps you from
discovering new things which is
paramount to surviving one of the few
good parts of ancestors with practically
zero tutorials ancestors forces you to
be experimental in order to succeed
there's joy to be had in bashing
different items together to see what
happens and then compiling and testing
hypotheses as much as I was frustrated
by needing to redo the entire process of
creating the fishing spear and repeated
playthroughs
felt genuine accomplishment and figuring
out the first time most of Ancestors
puzzles can be solved with logical sense
so the challenge comes in figuring out
where to find the materials you think
you need granted this being a game there
are occasionally arbitrary hurdles you
need to jump through to build certain
tools but you'll typically only find
these associated to more advanced
late-game tasks you don't get to enjoy
much of the satisfaction and discovering
new things and regularly evolving though
as predators repeatedly sneak up on you
and interrupt your efforts historically
it makes sense you're so powerless as
our ape ancestors undoubtedly lived many
more years as prey than predator but in
the context of a video game the constant
barrage of spawning enemies that you
can't really deal with gets in the way
of the gameplay loop of learning
responding and evolving it's a roadblock
that's only toppled once you acquire the
skills and tools to put up an adequate
defense but since so much has to be done
to get to that point contending with
large predators in the early hours of
the game feels unfair the closest you've
come to feeling safe while playing as
well you're up in the trees you spend a
lot of time in the branches as a result
but unfortunately there's no easy way to
travel between them you can climb
practically anything in ancestors
providing you have the stamina so
scrambling up into a tree is a quick
painless process however with no way to
easily course correct yourself while
swinging you typically only get to enjoy
a few seconds of fast-paced energetic
movement before you run out of branch
plummet to earth and possibly break your
legs and that's a shame because tree
traversal is pretty fun once you've got
the swing of things
ancestors the humankind Odyssey lingers
for far too long in its most toilsome
aspects the game does reward initial
experimentation that then asks you to
repeat processes over and over again
without any means of securing your
legacy it's an absolute grind to reach
the closest that ancestors has to an
endgame goal and one costly mistake can
erase everything you've accomplished
what small satisfaction the game does
provide is consistently ruined by
violent predators though the threat does
lessen once you evolve enough but as it
stands investing in ancestors journey
demands too much effort for too little
reward
[Music]
you